[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the cast of the fantastic
beasts films more specifically we're
going to be discussing the direction of
the fantastic piece films and how they
were impacted by the substitution of
johnny depp vermaz mikkelsen in the role
of primary antagonist gelet grindelwald
now when the fantastic beasts films
first hit theaters in spite of our
awareness of grindelwald's presence we
were all at first under the impression
that the main antagonist was going to be
percival graves played by colin farrell
however towards the end of the film it
is revealed that percival graves was
actually gelat grindelwald played by
johnny depp in disguise
with that said we only witnessed depp's
grindelwald for a very brief period in
this film after the first film had ended
and grindelwald's true identity had been
revealed
depp ended up reprising his role as
grindelwald in 2018's fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald
in this film we got much more of a look
into depth's portrayal of the famous
dark wizard and i certainly wasn't
disappointed but then disaster struck
after an ongoing legal battle involving
johnny depp amber heard the sun
newspaper and some accusations of libel
johnny depp was dropped by warner
brothers
being asked to leave the franchise just
as filming for the third installment had
begun
warner brothers said the following
johnny depp will leave the fantastic
beasts franchise we thank him for his
work on the film so far
fantastic beast 3 is currently in
production and the role of gaelic
grindelwald will be rescheduled the film
will hit theaters in the summer of 2022
in the end johnny ended up losing the
libel case against the sun
but convinced of his innocence did end
up suing amber heard the trial of which
i'm sure you've seen plastered all over
youtube in the last month on november 6
2020
johnny had this to say of his departure
from the fantastic beasts film franchise
in light of recent events i would like
to make the following short statement
firstly i'd like to thank everybody who
has gifted me with their support and
loyalty secondly i wish to let you know
that i've been asked to presign by
warner brothers from my role as
grindelwald in fantastic beasts and i
have respected and agreed to that
request
finally i wish to say this the surreal
judgment of the court in the uk will not
change my fight to tell the truth and i
confirm that i plan to appeal my resolve
remains strong and i intend to prove
that the allegations against me are
false
my life and career will not be defined
by this moment in time
thank you for reading sincerely johnny
depp
with johnny depp gone there was a big
hole in the franchise
the main antagonist was gone
without an antagonist there's no film to
be had and for a while it was looking
like the fantastic beast films between
actor drama a script rewrite and lower
than expected box office performance
we're going to be scrapped altogether
however as they say in show business the
show must go on
with production of the third film
already in motion warner bros were left
frantically searching for his
replacement
and right off the bat there were many
names thrown into the mix
however one name came up more than any
other across the internet
maz mickelson
it didn't take long for them to cast him
in the role as shortly after the
dropping of depp he was officially
announced as the new dark wizard
but despite his willingness to accept
the role and take the torch from johnny
mickelson has been nothing but
respectful towards the former fantastic
beast star releasing the following
statement on the matter
job-wise it's obviously super
interesting and nice mickelson said it's
also a shocker that it came after what
happened which is just super sad i wish
both of them the best
these are sad circumstances i hope both
of them will be back in the saddle again
really soon
additionally during a discussion about
mickelson's new film another round the
actor was asked how his take on the
villainous character will differ from
depths well it's going to be me so
that's a difference mickelson quipped
then he got serious
no this is the tricky part we're still
working it out there has to be a bridge
between what johnny did and what i'm
going to do
and the same time i also have to make it
my own
but also we have to find a few links and
some bridges so it doesn't completely
detach from what he's already
masterfully achieved and after much
anticipation
just last month we were able to see mass
in action for the very first time in
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore
so now that we've seen both men play the
dark wizard one big question remains
who did it better
johnny depp or maz mickelson let's break
down the pros and cons of each the first
thing that i want to address in this
matter is that some fans have been
unable to accept mass as grindelwald
simply due to the issue of continuity
how can we the fans be expected to
forget that someone else played the role
before
and to those people i say this
what about richard harris being replaced
by michael gambon as dumbledore
and what about rishi bremner being
replaced by rafe fines as voldemort in
addition to those two major ones there
were many other actor changes throughout
the harry potter films and at the end of
the day it didn't damage the franchise
people were still able to continue to
enjoy the film series and many people
didn't even notice
dumbledore and voldemort are both main
characters and the films were able to
continue to thrive
so there's no reason that replacing
grindelwald should be the nail in the
coffin for fantastic beasts the next
point that people made was that johnny
depp had spent far too much time as
grindelwald to be replaced
but in reality with the release of the
third film the truth is that maz and
johnny have shared a similar amount of
grindelwald screen time
yes johnny was in two films but what we
have to remember is that his role in the
first film was fairly minor which meant
limited screen time
i don't have the exact data on how many
minutes each actor has played the
notorious dark wizard but i'd be willing
to bet that it's a similar amount which
helps this comparison with those two
points out of the way i want to dissect
their performances based on a few
different pieces of criteria the
criteria will be as follows
one look
two vocals accent expression inflection
style of speech diction
three charisma four physicality
gestures facial expressions movement
five believability immersiveness and six
accuracy with relation to harry potter
canon and with those points laid out
let's dive in
kicking things off with look i'm going
to have to give it to maz mickelson
johnny depp's white hair heterochromia
different coloured eyes and hairstyle
all seemed a bit dramatic as if his
character's appearance had been
developed for film
the look of mass was a lot more
believable and more importantly
consistent with the rest of the world
around him
my biggest overarching criticism of
depp's appearance was his spiky hair
which just doesn't seem in line with the
20s or 30s
next vocals in this department i'm going
to have to give a point to both actors
as i think that they're each able to
nail different aspects of the vocal
component
in terms of accent mass who is danish
was far more believable but in terms of
expression i'd have to give it to johnny
next charisma
now as any good actor knows charisma is
a vital component to an acting
performance the ability to appeal to and
enchant the viewer in this respect i
don't think that either actor
outperformed the other they merely
enchanted the audience in their own way
with that said i found mas to be more
charismatic and i think that the opinion
on this is going to vary heavily from
person to person up next we have
physicality looking at it from the
perspective of gestures movement and
facial expression
while i think that mars was spot on with
regards to his gesturing and facial
expressions it's hard to ignore johnny's
movement and his ability to capture the
audience with his physical presence i'll
give this one to johnny
believability immersiveness
both men were believable grindelwalds
but one issue that i had with deb is
that it's well johnny depp
when i saw him i didn't think that's
grindelwald i thought oh it's johnny
depp playing grindelwald i think that if
his physical appearance had been more
dialed in matching what i expected
grindelwald to look like this problem
would have been alleviated to some
extent from a performance standpoint
however johnny did an excellent job
maz was slightly more believable for me
last up we have accuracy with relation
to canon
according to harry potter lore young
gaelic grindelwald had golden blonde
hair and a wild handsome face
middle-aged grindelwald had light blonde
hair and a thin white mustache and older
grindelwald had gray hair with no
mustache johnny depp plays grindelwald
from 1926 to 1928 making him 44 to 46
years old and maz mickelson plays
grindelwald in 1932
making him 50 years old bearing this in
mind from a canon perspective both
portrayals are reasonably accurate
johnny depp's grindelwald possesses the
light blonde hair that he purportedly
sported in middle age though it does
look more white and the slightly older
grindelwald played by maz sports gray
hair and no moustache both physical
descriptions are fairly consistent with
canon the other important characteristic
derived from canon is that grindelwald
is charming
and in this respect i think maz did a
slightly better job
not to say johnny did a bad job
in conclusion i think that maz did just
a little bit better than johnny in the
role
but that's just my opinion
maz just better fits the picture of
grindelwald i always had in my head i'd
give maz an a minus and johnny a b-plus
what do you guys think who did you
prefer and why
leave a comment down below
if you enjoy the content please be sure
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you